Hillary Clinton unexpectedly lost the
states of Pennsylvania Ohio Michigan
Wisconsin and Iowa those are states that
have gone Democratic in past elections
the question is why did they switch this
time the reasons really you can look for
them in the out states of those regions
in central and western Pennsylvania
outside Pittsburgh and Philadelphia
outside Cleveland Columbus in Cincinnati
Ohio
outside Detroit in Grand Rapids Michigan
outside Milwaukee and Madison Wisconsin
into the whole state of Iowa what hurt
Hillary Clinton they're number one
economy these are areas that feel left
behind Donald Trump appealed to them
with his program number two was
condescension Hillary Clinton called
people voting for Trump deplorable sand
irredeemable is implicit racist that
doesn't win you votes and the third
thing was honesty the out states went
heavily against Richard Nixon and the
Republicans during the Watergate they
went against Hillary Clinton and her
secret email server and the Democrats in
2016
[Music]